في خبر عاجل افاد مراسل الجزيره في فلسطين
ان اعدادا كبيره من جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي معززه بقوات خاصه اقتحمت مدينه
جنين
ومخيمها قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
اذا هذه هي المعلومات التي لدينا عن
اقتحام المخيم في جنين ومعنى الان مدير
مكتب الجزيره معنا من رام الله وليد
العمري وليد ماذا عن تفاصيل هذا الاقتحام
هذا التصعيد الاخير
قوات كبيره من جيش الاحتلال تتقدمها قوات
من الكوماندوز والمستعربين المعروفه
بالقوات الخاصه اقتحمت مدينه جنين وتوجهت
مباشره الى منطقه مخيم جنين وهناك باشرت
بمحاصره منزل في منطقه شارع مهيوب الواقع
في الناحيه الشرقيه من المخيم والمعلومات
التي وردتنا من شهود العيان وايضا من
الزملاء هناك بان تبادلا لاطلاق النار وقع
مع مقاومين فلسطينيين في المنطقه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه تحديدا سرايا القدس تقول بان
مقاتليها اشتبكوا مع قوات الاحتلال وان
الاشتباكات متواصله لكن القوات التي دخلت
قوات كبيره حسب كل شهود العيان هذا
الاقتحام او هذا التوغل الاسرائيلي الجديد
في مدينه جنين هو ربما الاول منذ اكثر من
شهر لانه كان هناك نوع من الهدوء او على
الاقل ان القوات الاحتلال لم تقم
باقتحامات وان ياتي في ساعات او ما بعد
الظهر فهذا ايضا مؤشر على ان قوات
الاحتلال كما تقول مصادرها لديها معلومات
وقد توغلت من اجل القيام اما بعمليه
اعتقال او عمليه تصفيه كما قلت القوات
كبيره جدا حسب شهود العيان توجهت مباشره
الى منطقه المنطقه الشرقيه من المخيم
وتحديدا الى منطقه الشارع مهيوب حيث حصلت
عدد من المنازل وهناك اشتباكات
بدات مع مقاومين فلسطينيين في نفس المنطقه
لم يبلغ حتى الان عن اصابات لكن واضح بان
التوغل الاسرائيلي الجديد
على مخيم الجنين تحديدا والذي اخترقت من
خلالها قوات الاحتلال مدينه الجيم وتوجهت
الى هناك
ياتي في ساعات ما بعد الظهر وهذا ربما كان
لافتا في البدايه كانت قوات الاحتلال
تتوغل وتقوم بعملياتها العسكريه
واعتداءاتها في ساعات الليل او الفجر ثم
اصبحت تقوم بها في ساعات الصباح الان هي
تقوم بهذا الاعتداء مباشره في ساعات ما
بعد الظهر